next up a story that you will appreciate
the guardian reports that the term
hangry is a madeup word for being hungry
and angry at the same time and a study
has found that indeed people who are
hangry have a difficult time regulating
their temperature due to a drop in blood
sugar this is a scientific fact which
makes you more likely to argue when
you're peckish so Hubert my my Huma do
you get angry yes I get angry when I'm
hungry and now now I get angry after
I've eaten as well double w so you're
hangry and cheese full yeah I am yeah if
it's cheese or coffee or uh uh porridge
oatmeal terrible I could kill after
those things really yeah okay so angry
before angry after y love it okay next
up is a story that's all about my
favorite part of the evening it's going
home because now that's where I'm at in
life slate reports that the Irish
goodbye is okay why why we should all
leave parties without a word the author
writes that we should all spend less
time in places where we don't actually
want to be do you believe in the Irish
exit it's called the French exit isn't
it that's what I thought it was too and
now it's been Chang a film as a as a
novel I agree it's because that term has
been Reco coined as an Irish exit exit
but I always thought of it as the French
exit that's what I said my whole life
and now it's Irish I don't know what I
don't know what happened I don't Irish
they never leave they want another drink
and another one and another one so that
can't be right I but
a and he's G what is your recommendation
for a French exit how do you do it
uh it is more popular now I agree where
you just go people don't mind you text
you just say thank you that was lovely
yeah sorry a bit of a panic kids I use
them for everything disaster at home
child emergency and you're gone whenever
my kids get sick I cuz I won't say
anything about them I you think it jines
them yes exactly but when they are I'm
like oh the kids are sick I can't yeah
it gets me out of everything well I lie
about them being sick the whole time
maybe that's why they are sick the whole
time
Hugh what's the thing that you haven't
done in your personal life that you
still want to do and what's the thing in
your professional life that you still
want to do and haven't done
yet I've done my personal life I'm very
happily married great girl lovely
children done finished
cooked uh professionally I know you know
I I want to finish that book I wrote
half a novel and I need to finish it is
it because that made me nicer is it
fiction or is fiction fiction how how
will you find the time to write the
second half well I won't ever and then
I'll die unsatisfied miserable well you
were gonna do that probably anyway
regard yeah
[Music]
yeah